companies governments countries
individuals could do to make the world a
better place is be honest that's the
first step to actually be honest it's
fine to make commitments it's fine to
make pledges it's fine to say we'll do
this and that but unless it's actually
executed unless the the the promise is
is made real then it's kind of pointless
and it's very easy to make pledges very
easy to to save your lives in that and
this and that and never do it so I do I
like people to be honest and I think
that works from from governments and
corporations up down to the individual
if people say I'm going to do something
positive and it could be something
really simple like there be more
environmentally conscious conscious or
for governments to say actually we say
we're going to do this we'll go ahead
and execute it and make sure there's
some sort of follow I think the time for
empty promises has gone and people
should focus on honesty